elon musk the spacex founder is still
determined on his company's aim of
creating a human presence on mars using
its starship rockets to carry people to
and from the earth
meanwhile spacex has some milestones to
undertake before starship could carry
passengers and take giant strides
now i can almost hear you thinking about
what could be the milestones
it's all about the capacity now musk
with spacex has taken a giant milestone
with the vision of an insane new rocket
factory to build more raptor engines
you know what you have to see the
incredible things this new rocket is
about to churn out
watch on welcome back to our channel if
you haven't already make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell
so you're notified every time we upload
a new video
hey let me briefly talk first about the
general outlook of the spacex facility
and tests the headquarters
of spacex is located in hawthorne
california it equally serves as the
firm's main manufacturing plant
spacex operates a significant operation
in research in redmond washington
and has a touch factory in texas it is
operating three launch sites while the
fourth site is under construction the
company has regional offices in virginia
texas and washington the firm has its
first rocket development and test
facility in mcgregor texas
each of the spacex rocket engines is
tested and carried out in rocket test
stands at mcgregor at the same time the
testing of larger starship prototypes is
undertaken in the spacex south texas
launch site close to brownsville texas
now let's go to the crux of the matter
continue watching to see the giant
strides of the new rocket factory musk
reveals that spacex is building the
biggest and most advanced rocket engine
factory globally in central texas to
assist the rising capacity of super
heavy and starship this factory at
mcgregor would be the firm's second
rocket engine production facility and
would develop raptor 2 engines the tesla
ceo said that this new rocket factory
would be in mcgregor due to the
challenges in the south texas facility
according to him
the challenges of operating at starbase
left us with no choice but to put engine
production in mcgregor meanwhile spacex
already has a huge presence in texas
even in mcgregor where the firm owns a
testing facility to research and
manufacture thrusters and new rocket
engines and also for testing of finished
engines and their components
the firm leases 4 280 acres and hires
500 workers in mcgregor
and earmarked 10 million dollars for
infrastructural works at the site
wait what are spacex's raptors they are
engines of full flow
stage combustion cycle rockets made for
use at starship launch vehicles
practically speaking the insane new
rocket factory would be the biggest
output rocket facility ever constructed
it would produce hundreds of raptor
engines every
year to outfit numerous interplanetary
starship fleets plus the earthbound
super heavy boosters which would send
them to the moon
earth orbit mars and even beyond on july
2021 the tesla ceo affirmed that the new
rocket factory would be the most
advanced and largest output rocket
engine worldwide
he revealed this plan after displaying
an exciting set of 10 advanced raptor
engines stationed at the production site
of the boko chica starship
spacex factory what's more spacex
installs three raptor engines and the
first functional super heavy boosters
prototype for the new rocket project
on july 11 musk said that spacex has
agreed on a vital super heavy's design
aspect determining that operational
starship boosters would eventually be
outfitted with about 33
identical raptor engines this posits
that every two-stage starship vehicle
would need about 39 to 42 raptor engines
and 36 to 39 variants of sea level plus
three vacuum optimized engines featuring
larger nozzles musk reveals that the new
rocket factory would be a place to break
ground on a second raptor factory in
other words the factory will concentrate
on raptor 2 volume production at the
same time the california factory would
craft raptor vacuum and experimental
designs
specifically the raptor's present design
isn't enough thus the ceo states that
spacex's new rocket factory would
establish an upgraded or advanced
raptor 2 engine increasing the maximum
thrust to about 230 tons apart from the
cutting off of small structural
components needed for engine gimbaling
on 20 booster raptors all starship
engines excluding three to six vacuum
variants would be identical this
insane factory situated at the firm's
expansive mcgregor texas location would
produce between 800 and 1000 raptor 2
engines yearly as stated the production
of raptor vacuums would still be at
spacex's hawthorne california
headquarters the raptor 2 to be
developed at the new rocket factory
would mirror the family of spacex's
merlin engine consisting of two sea
level and vacuum variants for over a
decade
moreover with a single big volume of
variance raptor 2 production would be
very efficient and can simply outpace
other big liquid engine production since
history at 800 to 1000 engines every
year
significantly the yearly production of a
single variant of any big liquid rocket
engine since history won't be close to
the height musk wants to reach for
spacex's raptor 2 production at the new
rocket factory including the soviet
union's production of soyuz between 1970
and 1980.
musk who founded spacex in 2002 is
confident of raptor 2 production and
subsequent results he believes that
spacex will take humans to mars in 2026.
in december 2020 he said that it's an
achievable goal
about six years from now spacex plans to
send a starship rocket without crew in
two years in another development musk
reveals that he wants to use this new
rocket factory to help fulfill his aim
for a city on mars in 2050. he said that
the engines would be required for a
fleet of rockets that would be used for
a 10-year time frame to develop the city
he predicts that it will take him 20
years to create the city
spacex the first private firm to take
astronauts to orbit
and the iss international space station
in 2020
is developing a starship and a satellite
the starship would be developed with the
production of raptor 2.
starship is funded privately and intends
to be the main spacex orbital drive once
completed and it would supplant the
already falcon heavy
falcon 9 plus dragonfleet and it will
possess the biggest ever payload
capacity of a rocket musk has repeatedly
said that he developed a rocket firm
because he wants to colonize mars
he argued that humanity should spread to
a second planet as survival insurance
for him the production of raptor 2 at
spacex's insane new rocket factory will
make it come to fruition what's your
opinion on this raptor 2 massive
production in the new rocket factory do
you think that spacex can build a city
on mars by 2050 we want to hear your
opinion on these
leave us a comment below in the meantime
if you enjoyed this video
make sure to give it a like and check
out more awesome ones on the simply tech
channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time